année olympique oblige les journées du
patrimoine étaient sportives les
amateurs de la petite reine s'étaient
donné rendez-vous au Vélodrome national
de montinil le Bretonneux ce 16
septembre histoire du complexe de son
architecture ou des entraînements des
cyclistes de nombreux curieux étaient
venus admirer la piste et le terrain de
BMX construit en 2014 ça se passe une
fois dans notre vie à proximité donc
autant être partie prenante et puis
voilà pouvoir bénéficier de de toutes
les animations autour on apprend
l'histoire euh le rapport avec avec
Louis XIV Versailles donc effectivement
quand on va voir le vélodrome on n pense
pas forcément à La Verrière c'est le
château qui se dévoilait aux amateurs de
Bellepierre bâti dès le 16e siècle ce
lieu a été racheté par la MGEN dans les
années 50 pour y installer un centre
psychiatrique visite de sa chapelle dans
le style des ateliers d'art sacré ou de
ces salons richement décorés une
occasion unique pour les cinquantinois
d'observer un lieu d'ordinaire
inaccessible au public je pensais
absolument pas qu'il était comme ça et
non non c'est une bonne découverte
vraiment de pouvoir être de d'être
imprégné du lieu en fait les volumes
l'architecture extérieure et intérieure
mais l'harmonie des volumes le parc
aussi qui est quelque chose de
d'intéressant à découvrir à parcourir
jardin historique édifice religieux ou
sites industriel en France ces journées
du patrimoine réunissent chaque année
plus de 100 millions de visiteurs sur
16000 sites différents